-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the attic.
Last week, my dog Frisbee sat
in that tiny chair back there.
Many of you Instagrammed it,
justifying an otherwise
pointless purchase
of a chair too small
for an adult
and too boring for a child.
Well, now that the chair's
been used on TV,
my accountant informs me
that it is a tax write-off,
which is great.
Unfortunately,
my accountant is also a wasp,
so I'm not sure how much
he knows about human finance.
He spent most of his time
at the accounting firm
Ernst & Stung.
[ Laughs ] And you can tell
he's an accountant
because he wrote that joke.
And, speaking of jokes --
[ Ding ]
The president
is reeling politically
from his deadly incompetence
during the coronavirus pandemic
and, now, he and his
sycophants on state TV
are trying to distract from that
by obsessively spinning
wild conspiracy theories
about Barack Obama.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Well, it's just another day
in the rolling nightmare
that is the Trump era.
I wish I could just walk
outta his presidency
the way he walked out of that
press conference on Monday
when reporters dared to ask him
even mildly
challenging questions.
-Okay, anybody else?
Please, go ahead.
In the back, please.
-I have two questions.
-No, it's okay.
We'll go over here.
-But you pointed to me.
I have two questions,
Mr. President.
-Next. Next, please.
-But you called on me.
-I did, and you didn't respond
and, now, I'm calling on
-Sorry. I just wanted to let --
-the young lady in the back.
Please.
-I just wanted to let
my colleague finish. But can I
-Okay.
-ask you a question, please?
-Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
-But you called on me.
-Thank you very much.
-You called on me.
-You know,
it's a lot less dramatic
when you try to storm out
of your own press conference
and in front of the cameras,
no less.
It's like trying to walk
out of a meeting on Zoom
and forgetting
where your door is.
"Alright, you know what?
This is ridiculous.
I quit!
Goodbye, everybody!
Goodbye!
Had it with you.
Also, could you guys log out?
I need this Zoom room
for my dog's birthday party
in like 10 minutes.
Yeah, I don't wear pants!
Not shoes, but pants.
Also, dude,
you can't just walk out.
You left all your props
on the table.
-This major commitment
is possible
because of the
massive mobilization
of American industry, including
Puritan Medical Products,
U.S. Cotton, Abbott Labs,
and Thermo Fisher.
Some of these
incredible companies
produce and produced
rapidly for us
and their products are here
with us this afternoon.
These are all different products
that were literally
just developed,
if you can imagine that,
and these are the best machines
and the best equipment
anywhere in the world.
-Yo, cool.
It's like QVC,
if the "C" stood
for coronavirus.
Where have I seen Trump
pull that move before?
-There's the water company.
I mean, we sell water.
Trump Steaks.
Where are the steaks?
Do we have steaks?
Right.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We have Trump Steaks.
And, by the way,
if you wanna take one,
we'll charge you about, what?
Fifty bucks a steak.
[ Laughter ]
No, I won't.
The magazine is great.
Anybody want one?
Here, take one.
And, by the way, the winery --
you see the wine --
we make the finest wine,
as good a wine
as you can get
anywhere in the world
and I know the press
is extremely honest,
so I won't offer them any,
but, if they want,
they can take a bottle
of wine home.
-His timing on the free wine
was four years too early.
He could be rakin' it
in right now.
Also, wine?
You should be handin' out
tequila shots
at your press conference.
[ As Trump ]
Everyone get blackout drunk
'cause I'd love if we all
forgot this ever happened.
The president pulled the same
move for coronavirus tests
that he previously used
for his crappy steaks and wine.
If the pattern holds,
we'll be back here
in four years
with Trump selling steaks,
nose swabs,
and zombie repellant.
Living through this presidency
means living in a constant state
of being both shocked and numb
at the same time.
In fact, that's what
they're counting on.
One advisor to the White House
Coronavirus Task Force
told The Washington Post,
"The question is will people
become anesthetized to it?"
Well, I'm pretty sure Trump
has been anesthetized
since day one.
His presidency has been
like one long YouTube video
of a kid comin' home
from the dentist.
[ As Trump ]
Is this real life?
And Trump's face
is always frozen
in that dead-eyed grimace,
like he wears a night cream
made of Novocaine,
which, incidentally,
you can find on the Goop store,
under Moon Powders.
Of course, the reality is
Americans are not
anesthetized to it.
The vast majority of Americans
overwhelmingly support
social distancing measures
and say public health
is more important
than prematurely reopening
the economy.
And, in a new poll
out yesterday,
54% of Americans continue to say
the U.S. government
is doing a poor job
preventing the spread
of COVID-19
and only 36% say
they consider Trump
a trusted source of information
about the outbreak.
Wow!
That is shocking.
I mean, how could you not
trust the guy who said
heat would kill
the coronavirus,
that cases would go
down to zero,
that it would go away in April,
that a vaccine
would come out soon,
that hydroxychloroquine
could be a gift from heaven,
and that it could be cured
by eating Lysol wipes
out of a salad bowl
with a fork and a knife?
[ As Trump ]
And, for a little flavor,
throw in some croutons
and some balsamic disinfectant.
And, if you compare
Trump's approval rating
to governors and foreign leaders
who've handled
the outbreak competently,
they look even worse,
like New Zealand's
prime minister,
Jacinda Ardern,
who's handling has won more
than 80% public approval,
well above any leader
in the Group of Seven
wealthy democracies.
Or the popularity of governors
who have responded much more
aggressively to the crisis
on both sides of the aisle.
-In Massachusetts,
84% approve
of how Republican
Governor Charlie Baker
has handled
the coronavirus outbreak,
according to a new poll
out this week.
California's Democratic
governor, Gavin Newsom,
hit 83% approval of his
performance last month,
nearly double his
pre-coronavirus numbers.
Jay Inslee, in Washington,
is also way up.
He received a 75% positive
approval rating in another poll.
-83%!
Do you know what
Donald Trump would do
for an 83% approval rating?
I don't think he's that high
among Trump's ages 30 to 60.
And Trump is clearly aware
that governors
are much more popular
than he is
because he sees their numbers
and wants credit for them.
On Tuesday, he tweeted,
"Remember this, every Governor
who has sky high approval
on their handling
of the Coronavirus,
and I am happy for them all,
could in no way
have gotten those numbers,
or had that success,
without me and the
Federal Governments help.
From Ventilators to Testing,
we made it happen!
Also, Hillary only won
the popular vote
because people hated me,
so you're welcome."
And, no, you didn't
make it happen.
You can't tell states to get
lost when they want help,
then claim credit
when they succeed.
This isn't Don Jr.'s
sixth grade science project.
[ As Trump ]
Idiot. You're not supposed
to pour baking soda
in the volcano. You're supposed
to pour it in your mouth,
clean out the germs.
Also, if you get an "A,"
tell the teacher it was my idea.
But anything else,
anything lower,
you're on your own.
When states came to you,
desperate for help
with ventilators and testing,
you and your doltergeist
son-in-law told them,
over and over again,
they were on their own.
-It's going to be up to the
states to use that capability.
The states have local points
where they can go.
A governor can call the mayors
and the mayors
can call representatives
and everything is perfect
and that's the way it should
work and always should work.
The states should've been
building their stockpiles.
We have almost 10,000
in our stockpile.
We've been building it
and we've been supplying it.
But the states should be
building. We're a backup.
We're not an ordering clerk.
We're a backup.
-The notion of the
federal stockpile was
it's supposed to be
our stockpile.
It's not supposed to be
states' stockpiles
that they then use.
They should know
how many ventilators
they have in their states.
And, by the way, some governors
you speak to, or senators,
and they don't know what's
in their state.
You know, some governors,
I'll speak to
and they'll know,
to the number,
how many ventilators
they have in their state
'cause that's the first thing
a good manager will do.
-How would you know
what a good manager
is supposed to do?
You're less qualified
for your job
than that one
production assistant
on a movie set who's only there
because their dad
runs the studio.
You know, the one
who shows up three hours late,
in a fedora and sandals,
and says he was busy,
takin' photos of graffiti
down by the 405.
"Tyler, can you just
hold the slate?"
"Nah, man, I'm gonna go
grab a coconut water
and take a nap
in Mr. Hanks' trailer."
Also, the job is clearly
wearin' on you, bud,
because this is what you
looked like four years ago.
What happened, man?
Did you get
bit on the neck
by Stephen Miller?
You used to look like
an all-American preppy
and, now, you look like
you're gonna
dart out of a coral reef
to snag a passing fish.
If you get any paler,
you're gonna start blending
into the walls
at the White House.
Trump knows he's never
gonna get good marks
after his horrific handling
of the coronavirus pandemic,
which has left over 80,000 dead
and the unemployment rate
at its highest
since the Great Depression.
Just yesterday, the nation's
top infectious disease expert,
Dr. Anthony Fauci,
warned of needless
suffering and death
if states reopen too soon
and said that
"little spikes of coronavirus
could turn
into full-blown outbreaks,"
and, yet, instead of taking
that danger seriously
and correcting his mistakes,
the porridge-brained
adult toddler
who's in charge
of keeping us all safe
has spent the last few days
obsessively rage-tweeting
vague conspiracy theories
about his predecessor,
like when he tweeted out the
words "OBAMAGATE" in all-caps.
And, when he was asked
to explain
what the so-called
Obamagate scandal
he keeps tweeting about
actually was, he just couldn't.
-Mr. President, in one
of your Mother's Day tweets,
you appear to accuse
President Obama
of "The biggest political crime
in American history, by far!"
-Yeah.
-Those were your words.
What crime, exactly,
are you accusing
President Obama of committing
and do you believe
the Justice Department
should prosecute him?
-Obamagate.
It's been going on
for a long time.
It's been going on from before
I even got elected
and it's a disgrace
that it happened
and, if you look
at what's gone on
and, if you look at, now,
all of this information
that's being released.
And, from what I understand,
that's only the beginning.
Some terrible things happened
and it should never be allowed
to happen in our country again.
And you'll be seeing
what's going on over the next,
over the coming weeks and I wish
you'd write honestly about it,
but, unfortunately,
you choose not to do so.
Yeah, John, please.
-What is the crime, exactly,
that you're accusing him of?
-You know what the crime is.
The crime is very obvious
to everybody.
-No, we don't, and, apparently,
[ Laughing ] neither do you.
Trump's so lazy,
he can't even be bothered
to come up with the details
of his own fake scandal anymore.
[ As Trump ]
Look, I came up
with the name, okay?
How much do you want me to do?
It's like a screenwriter
who pitches a movie
based on the title, alone.
"Alright, you guys ready?
Called 'Death Train.'
Action movie
starring Vin Diesel."
Oh, that's great.
What's it about?
"It's got like explosions,
tons of explosions!"
Okay, cool. And, then,
you know, what happens?
"Like lots of like fast,
super fast cars."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, and what's the plot?
"It's Vin Diesel, buddy.
You don't need any of that."
Trump says "Obamagate"
like he's playing
a version of Taboo
where the only words that aren't
forbidden are Obama and gate.
[ As Trump ]
So it's like he's Obama,
so it's Obamagate
and it's Obama.
All the information on it.
It's Obamagate.
Come on, you know,
it's Obamagate.
It's Obamagate.
It was [bleep]
The answer was [bleep]
And, now, the president's allies
in the GOP and right-wing media
are actually calling
on the Department of Justice
to prosecute Obama officials
and possibly even Obama himself
for whatever the hell
Obamagate is supposed to be.
-Bill Barr has found them out
and they are developing,
along with John Durham,
Bill Barr is,
a massive conspiracy case
against a host of people
in the Obama FBI and DOJ.
What Obama did in that office
was sedition on that day.
There's a conspiracy indictment
coming down the track.
-It's time we asked,
"What did Obama and Biden know
and when did they know it?"
People are constantly
phoning our offices,
wanting to know
when all the people
that did the injustice to Flynn
were gonna be prosecuted.
And I think they oughta
be prosecuted.
-Oh, yeah, people are
constantly phoning your offices,
wanting to know when Obama
will be prosecuted?
Who are these people?
[ As Trump ]
Uh, yeah, hello.
Uh, my name is Mr., uh,
Flag Desk Phone.
I'm a farm person. I'm from
whatever state you're from
and I want you
to prosecute Obama
for whatever it is he did.
You know what it is.
-Also, I'm glad to hear
Joe diGenova is back
on the airwaves.
Do you remember this guy?
I'm sure you don't,
unless you're confusing him
with the "Time to make
the doughnuts" guy.
He's a right-wing lunatic
who used to be
on Fox News a lot
and who was
on Trump's legal team
for like a second before Trump,
I'm guessing, saw his mustache
and told him he looks like
an extra from "Boogie Nights."
DiGenova doesn't have an office.
He just keeps all his papers
in the back of a taxicab.
If you, you know,
wanna reach him,
you probably have to call
a butcher shop in Secaucus
and wait a few hours,
until he's back from the OTB.
He looks like he got kicked
out of Studio 54
for eatin' meatballs
on the dance floor.
"I warned you once already, Joe.
People can't dance when they're
slippin' on the sauce.
They can't dance
the disco, Joe."
Anyway, diGenova is,
unfortunately,
someone the president listens to
and he, along with GOP senators
and other Trump allies,
are now calling
for the president's
political opponents,
including possibly even Obama
himself, to be prosecuted,
which is crazy because Obama
wasn't even in office
when any of the cases
in the Russia investigation
were brought.
They've already blamed Obama
for not stopping coronavirus
three years before it happened.
What else do we they wanna
blame Obama for?
[ As Trump ]
Obama's the one
who flushed the toilet
during that
Supreme Court hearing.
-And what the FCC
has said is that,
when the subject matter --
[ Toilet flushing ]
of the call ranges
to the topics,
then the call is transformed.
-[ As Trump ]
Don't get me wrong.
I don't blame him.
I mean, I think it's probably
all that roughage
Michelle makes him eat.
There's honestly
so much happening right now
that it's impossible
not to think
the very survival of our system
of government is at stake.
The attorney general
is shredding the rule of law
to protect the president's
political allies
and target his enemies.
The president's
favorite TV channels
are pushing deranged
propaganda about both
the origins of the
coronavirus pandemic
and the Russia investigation.
Senate Republicans are standing
in lockstep behind the president
as he spreads
conspiracy theories
and tries to use Americans
as cannon fodder
to prematurely
reopen the economy.
And, just yesterday,
the president's lawyers
were arguing that he is
above the law
in front of a Supreme Court
that includes
four conservative justices
appointed by presidents
who lost the popular vote.
Our government is like
the "Cats" movie --
to make it work,
we're gonna have to get rid
of all the dicks.
And, even then, it's, you know,
not gonna be great.
In fact, yesterday,
in front of the Supreme Court,
Trump's lawyers argued
that banks shouldn't have
to produce Trump's tax returns,
as required by law,
and that he should be granted
temporary presidential immunity.
Trump's lawyer Jay Sekulow
told the court,
"The president is not to be
treated as an ordinary citizen."
Well, I mean in a way, I agree
that this president shouldn't be
treated as an ordinary citizen,
but, I mean it more like
how you'd say
Godzilla shouldn't be treated
as an ordinary lizard.
And, yeah, I know there are some
of you out there who think,
"So what if he's
a radioactive sea monster?
He'd still make
a good pet for the kids."
So, amid a horrific
public health emergency
that most voters agree
he's basically mishandled,
the president is looking
to prosecute his
political opponents
and elevate himself
above the law.
That's because he knows
the coronavirus pandemic
and the cratering economy
threaten his political survival,
so he and his allies on state TV
are casting about
for anyone else to blame
and, now,
they're obsessing, as they have
for years, over Obama.
-"What did Obama know
and when did he know it?"
Also, documents revealing
bombshell new information
on what Barack Obama knew
about deep state spying.
-The Obama administration
really was poison
and they bullied a lotta people
into pretending it wasn't.
-Barack Obama's plan
to derail his successor unfolded
with very little opposition
along the way.
-It's not about FBI misbehavior.
It's about Obama.
-President Obama.
-Barack Obama.
-Obama.
-This guy's got some nerve,
Barack Obama.
-Fox hosts say the name Obama
like it's their safe word.
Their obsession with Obama
is akin to gossipy cheerleaders
spreading rumors
about the prom queen
because they're mad
she won't hang out with them.
"I heard Jessica told Jenna
to trick Donald
into hanging out with Vlad,
so somebody should look
into that, please."
I think the GOP and Fox News
would honestly rather live
in an alternate universe
where Obama was president,
and not Trump.
Then, they could at least lie
and tell themselves
they were a ragtag band
of rebels,
instead of the marketing
department for the Death Star.
"First of all, I think
we should change the name.
Yes, Lisa,
I know it was Vader's idea,
but I'm not afraid
of Darth Vader."
[ Asphyxiating ]
Look, over 80,000 Americans
have died,
another 33 million are
outta work,
and these people are still
obsessed with Barack Obama.
We're dealing
with a public health crisis,
an economic crisis,
and a crisis of democracy,
and the rule of law.
And, if we somehow make it
through all of that intact,
what we're seeing now...
-Should never be allowed
to happen
in our country again.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Please continue to give
to City Harvest.
Their work never stops,
as so many New Yorkers
turn to them to put food
on their tables.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.